[Musique]
jean marc jancovici est donc avec nous
bonjour jean marc ingénieur professeur à
l'école des mines
fondane fondateur cofondateur du cabinet
carbone 4 qui s'intéressent est l'une
des questions qu'on verra ensemble est
ce que peuvent faire les entreprises
dans l'ensemble de ces grandes questions
de transition climatique qui vont nous
occuper pendant une demi heure au moins
alors je vous le disais je parle jean
marc jancovici couramment c est donc je
sais que et c'est un élément qui m'avait
beaucoup perturbé vous dit écoutez c'est
simple les accords de paris faux 4% de
baisse de pipe
chaque année pour y arriver 1 4% de
baisse ou de pee-wee 4% de baisse de
pipe avec 4,5 je vous en accorde 50 et 5
de baisse de gaz à effet de serre et je
veux bien un point d'efficacité
énergétique énergétique carbone et c'est
donc 4 % de baisse de pib chaque année
pour y arriver on les a jean-marc oui et
je lis partout que ça sert à rien ah non
c'est pas que ça sert à rien il faut
bien voir que la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui et plus encore
celle qu on pourrait construire pour
demain est le résultat d'un siècle et
demi d'accumulation de co2 dans la post
d'accord mais là à falloir qu'on fasse
des efforts dans l'autre sens pendant un
siècle
c'est pas une fois donc là vous
constatez que ça ne sert à rien de faire
un effort ponctuel mais ça tu le sais on
sait depuis très longtemps
non mais 4% de baisse de pub là j'ai
maintenant je lis partout mais d'abord
est ce que c'est vrai ou pas je lis
partout s'il n'y a pas de baisse
significative bien qu'ils enrichissent
il y aura s'il y aura cette année
quelques pour cent de baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet serre dans le
monde bien géorgie 6 5% de cet ordre là
bon mais on voit le prix qu'on paye oui
mais si vous avez dirigé si vous avez
sécher l'école pendant 20 ans et que au
bout de la 21ème année vous décidez d'y
retourner c'est pas au bout de la
première semaine que vous avez rattraper
votre retard ni même au bout de 12 mois
donc là on a accumulé un passif pendant
un siècle et demi qui est aller en
croissant
on ne va pas corriger ça par un coup de
baguette magique en une semaine il en
une année ni même avis
non mais et c'est que la baguette
magique c'est pas une baguette magique
c'est une massue elles nous est tombée
en pleine figure et elle est
insupportable c'est à dire je ne savais
pas ce que ça attendez je savais pas ce
que ça voulait dire en fait en gros 4 %
de baisse de pub je me doutais bien que
c'était grave
mais je savais pas ce que ça voulait
dire à l'échelle mondiale en fait il ya
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas connu ça je
suis même pas sûr que 2008 ce soit 2 4%
de baisse de pub à l'échelle mondiale
c'est moins que ça bon ben je sais ce
que c'est c'est pas possible jean-marc
voilà si c'est possible c'est ce qui
nous attend malheureusement dès le début
de la fin des années 60 il ya des
dynamicien des systèmes web haïti alors
je sais que vous avez beaucoup la
technologie multi aucun problème les
mighty oak alley vous dites amène donc
dynamicien des systèmes lui est multi
ont publié une étude qui a été
vulgarisée sous le titre the limits
golfe et qui en france a été mal
traduite sous le terme halte à la
croissance mais en fait c'était a été
vulgarisée sous le nom de rapport du
club de rome en fait ce n'est pas le
rapport du juge et aidera au club de
rome et s'était fait par une équipe de
physiciens et de matheux et ils ont dit
à partir du moment où notre économie est
un système linéaire qui prend dans les
ressources naturelles qui transforme et
qui jette partir du moment où c'est ça
non seulement elle peut pas y avoir de
croissance infinie mais on peut même
prédire qu'après une phase de croissance
vous avez un pic et une phase de
décroissance donc à un moment vous
rentrez dans un déclin structurel
exactement comme votre corps comme le
mien au grand âge que nous avons eues
avec les cheveux blancs quand on a la
chance d'avoir des cheveux non mais y
aller mais une partie de ses
performances physiques les médias les
gains de productivité jean marc car
l'activité ça vous le savez mieux que
moi c'est quoi il faut il fera chine
les gains de production c'est des
machines c'est l'efficacité énergétique
ces cassettes énergétique c'est les
machines vous portez des vêtements qui
ont été faits par des machines
vous avez mangé à midi enfin si vous
avez mangé ce que je vous souhaite sinon
votre métier très très difficile
d vous avez mangé des choses qui ont été
plus cultivés par des machines
absolument mais bien sûr qu'ils ont été
transportés par des machines
réfrigérer par des mecs qui sont elles
mêmes de plus en plus efficaces sous
limite de ce que la physique nous
autorise alors je vais vous donner un
exemple tout con vous vous rappelez
peut-être qu'en physique dans vos jeunes
années vous avez vu que l'énergie
cinétique d'un objet c'est le car et
c'est là le pardon la moitié de la masse
folk art et la vitesse record donc ça
veut dire que vous prenez un objet d'une
masse de données que vous voulez a mené
à une vitesse donnée vous ne pourrez
jamais dépenser moins d'énergie pour ça
qu'un demi de mv2 vous pouvez invoquer
tous les économistes de la terre vous ne
pouvez pas c'est toute l'innovation de
la terre tous les gars fans de rap à la
physique voilà d'accord même google
même google de même que même terre qui
fait treize mille kilomètres de diamètre
et personnes avec mais jean-marc là il
s'agit pas de stagnation je comprends
c'est très intéressant et d'ailleurs il
ya des économistes qui c'est le grand
débat des économistes aujourd'hui la
fameuse stagnation séculaire
là vous me parlez d'une régression de 4
% du prix parents je vous dis fait
insupportable et je vous dis on en aura
d'autres oui mais alors là alors je vais
et notre culpabilité collective où notre
notre faute collective c'est de ne
jamais avoir envisagé cette possibilité
est donc d'avoir aucun plan qui sont
prêts pour ça aucun parce que pendant
très très longtemps et je vais un peu
vous taquinez vous savez que c'est une
marque de fabrique sur aucun plateau de
télé nulle part on a taquiné les
économistes et les hommes politiques en
leur disant très bien vous voulez la
croissance et admettons qu'elle soit pas
là vous avez un plan qui prennent non
mais même sur le réchauffement vous
retombez sur vous retombez sur je crois
que c'était c'est rené dumont campagne
présidentielle 1974 il dit absolument
tout et tout et tout est dit tout est
écrit tout dit dans et dans le fameux de
limites sauf on parle déjà du changement
climatique et de l'effet de serre et moi
j'ai en tête une série de notes d'un
ingénieur des mines absolument géniale
qui en 1990 avait tout compris
oui mais c'est le propre des prophètes
ce tour marqué donc il faut qu'il faut
que la profession à un moment tu
réalises pour qu'on commence à y croire
oui parce qu'on est des animaux gouverné
par nos sens
alors moi je vous dis aussi la prophétie
dix ans après la croissance la
décroissance elle existe et c'est pas
une prophétie c'est quelque chose qui
est très solidement argumentée et donc
on va commencer à le voir avec nos sens
et on va pas trouver ça drôle parce qu
on a justement
pas voulu le voir avec notre cortex et
donc on n'a rien préparé pour ça mais on
va ça veut dire et nous et vous et moi
qui sommes des csp + à peu près préservé
des aléas de la vie jusqu'à maintenant
on n'a pas encore commencé à sentir dans
notre cher ce qui est déjà en train de
se passer pour une partie de la
population française depuis dix ans tout
à fait déjà tout à fait non tout à fait
non mais je vous suis et je vous suis
tellement que ça veut dire que dans mon
propos c'est pas de dire enfin
ça veut dire que c'est insupportable ça
veut dire que les dégâts provoqués par
cette baisse de 4% du pipe chaque année
vont être bien pire est beaucoup plus
immédiats en termes de révolte en termes
de tout ce qu'on peut imaginer que le
réchauffement climatique
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre c'est à dire
qu'une partie de la baisse du pipe que
nous allons avoir à l'avenir sera dû en
fait la manière dont on a conçu la
convention économique jusqu'à maintenant
est une manière qui est impropre
compte tenu des problèmes que nous avons
aujourd'hui savait que l'économie vous
avez apprise à l'école comme moi du
reste il ya deux facteurs de production
qui sont tous les deux des facteurs
humains il ya le travail humain et il ya
le capital humain
absolument bon vous portez en
l'occurrence des vêtements qui
contiennent des fibres synthétiques
chaussures que vous avez un peu impolie
machin chouette dans la douleur de votre
est forcément france fait un peu de pub
pas totalement médine élevé payé
d'ailleurs parce que tout ce qui est
synthétique sur cette veste est un
dérivé de la pétrochimie
oui donc c'est du pétrole qui vient pas
du tout doléances voilà comme nos
masques comme nos masques et bien ce
pétrole mère nature nous a donné
gratuitement
oui vous avez rien payer pour la
formation du pétrole vous avez du métal
un peu quelques objets en métal sur vous
ce métal vient du minerai de fer
personne n'a payé pour la création du
minerai de fer sur terre c'est ça nous a
été donnée gratuitement par la nature
donc en fait si je prends un jargon un
tout petit peu comptable dans les coûts
de production jamais nulle part vous
allez trouver une dotation aux
amortissements pas ce qu'on tape dans
des ressources naturelles non
renouvelables et jamais nulle part vous
n'allez trouver des provisions pour
risques parce que nous créons des
perturbations futures qui auront un coup
tu fais une petite incidente j'ai vu
passer il ya pas longtemps et ça m'a
fait marrer parce que c'est l'université
de chicago donc celle de rockefeller et
friedman a quand même il ya deux
chercheurs de l'université de chicago
qui ont publié un papier quinzaine de
jours dans lequel ils disent
le coût des dégâts du changement
climatique si on prend un taux
d'actualisation qui est raisonnable donc
pas un truc dément et qu'on regarde sur
un horizon de plusieurs siècles
ça peut monter jusqu'à 600 mille dollars
la tonne de carbone auquel cas même avec
le quart de cette valeur un français
chaque année détruit dix fois plus qu'il
ne crée enfin qu'ils décrivent valeur
avec son pays deux choses là dessus et
attend des détails parce que je tiens
parce que c'est super important c'est
tout mais c'est assez super important et
je tiens à faire un peu de pédagogie des
trucs la convention économique que nous
utilisons aujourd'hui est totalement
inappropriée dans un monde fini en fait
elle marchait très bien dans mon infinie
dans un monde fini elle ne permet pas
d'anticiper ce qui va se passer on est
d'accord
six cent mille dollars la tonne de
carbone juste pour donner une idée aux
gens en ce moment les conventions vont
de ce ballet 20 à 100 euros la tonne de
carbone co2 par tonne de co2 la tonne de
co2 donc c'est quatre fois plus en
carbone vous allez lire bertrand badré
ancien directeur général de la banque
mondiale il a hashtag qui s'appelle mark
to planète c'est exactement ce que vous
décrivez c'est à dire il faut qu' il
faut rentrer dans le bilan des
entreprises en termes comptables
exactement l'arabie saoudite
ok vos réserves de pétrole valoriser
combien déprécier combien etc le mark to
planète comme on a le mark to market
on est d'accord là dessus l'oréal par
exemple dans une red commence à le faire
et dans une fête bon mais c'est pas sur
ce terrain là je vous emmenez moi en
fait je remarque c'est sûr alors je vous
ai dit qu'on allait cité du pascal
canfin donc ça vous inquiétez mais vous
allez voir donc
donc pascal canfin ses députés lrm et
président de la commission environnement
au parlement européen et qu'est ce qu'il
a dit hier
arrêtons de financer de grandes
infrastructures et des équipements sans
savoir comment ils se comporteront face
aux chocs climatiques
pourquoi est-ce que étant donné que la
lune la bataille est perdue ou en tout
cas insupportable
pourquoi est ce qu'on cherche pas à
s'adapter plutôt qu'à essayer de le
faire aussi mais on va devoir s'adapter
à deux évolutions simultanée et ça si
vous me connaissez si vous lisez
couramment de gens comme ici dans le
texte
vous n'allez pas être surpris par ce que
je vais dire ça fait des années et des
années que j'explique que
malheureusement l'inaction du moment
nous prépare un futur où on va se payer
2 emmerdements pour le prix d'un ça va
être le double effet kiss cool on va
avoir moins de ressources donc moins
d'économies pour gérer plus
d'emmerdements parce que le changement
climatique est un processus avec une
inertie considérable et par exemple un
truc que peu de vos confrères ont dit et
je trouve ça dommage parce que du coup
les gens n'ont pas assez peur entre
guillemets mais une bonne peur celle qui
fait comprendre que vraiment faut s'en
occuper
la dérive climatique des 20 prochaines
années est déjà écrite c'est à dire
allez embarquer dans nos émissions
passées d'accord donc et le climat de
2020 est perdue à jamais de toute façon
quoi qu'on fasse à l'avenir
d'accord on à partir de maintenant nos
enfants vont vivre dans un climat en
dérive et nos petits enfants vivront
dans un climat en dérive pour ceux qui
vivront etc jusqu'à la fin de l'humanité
parce que l'humanité va encore vivre
quelques milliers d'années et bien pour
les quelques milliers d'années qui
viennent le climat stable n'existera
plus donc on est sortis d'un état de
climat stable qui était celui qui a
permis la sédentarisation notre espèce
et qu'on connaissait depuis dix mille
ans et là on a mis en route une machine
infernale qui s'appelle la dérive
climatiques qu'on peut tamponné qu'on
peut l'imiter donc c'est à ça que
j'essaye de me de me consacrer être le
succès que l'on sait a vu ce qui se
passe le problème c'est les rationnels
combat mais a défini ses c'est pas
irrationnel non fini c'est fini c'est la
dérive s'est passé par la suite if ce
qui est différent et donc
c'est l'accumulation dans l'atmosphère
qui crée un stock qui ensuite ne se
résorbent que très lentement le surplus
de co2 qu on a rajouté dans l'atmosphère
adapte la cie demain matin on arrête les
émissions il faudra attendre plus de dix
mille ans pour qu'il disparaisse et
c'est quoi le double emmerdements le
premier emmerdements s'exprima de
délivrance et la dérive et le deuxième
emmerdements c'est que aujourd'hui ce
qui nous permet de transformer notre
environnement et de faire face à tous
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'énergie parce
que l'énergie c'est les croquettes pour
machines c'est à dire c'est ce qui nous
permet d'être iron man pour devrait être
tout à fait donc la machine sur le monde
dans le monde c'est iron man en pièces
détachées tout à fait et iron man en
pièces détachées a multiplié la
puissance musculaire de l'humanité par
un facteur 2 100 en ordre de grandeur
alors je vous la jouer à l'envers c'est
les dons que les machines qui produit si
les machines n'étaient pas là donc si on
n'avait ni pétrole ni gaz ni charbon et
marginalement pas de chutes d'eau et pas
nucléaire mais à l'échelle mondiale
c'est encore plus marginalement les
panneaux solaires et les éoliennes
si on n'avait pas pétrole gaz et charbon
enroulé pib mondial serait divisé par
deux sur wii mais on l'aura toujours ça
enfin c'est à dire vas y aura toujours
des sources d'énergie banon hydrogène
c'est hydrogène c'est un délire
d'ingénieurs ça n'existe pas à l'état
natif de manière significative non mais
on peut le créer assez facilement
notamment avec des centrales nucléaires
le physicien va vous dire que pour
obtenir de l'hydrogène en gros c'est le
premier électrolyse de l'eau
c'est le premier élément dans l'univers
plus abondants alors il ya énormément
d'hydrogène dans le soleil mais mais
mélonio jupons commandes il ya encore
plus hydrogène dans les galaxies
lointaines et dans l'ordre dans l'eau
dans l'eau jean marc peillen dans l'eau
sauf que dans l'eau il est cramponné à
l'oxygène et donc il faut employer de
l'énergie pour casser la liaison entre
il faut provoquer le divorce et ils
s'aiment beaucoup ces deux là d'un essai
orbeo et juliette et donc pour les
séparer vous allez devoir injecter de
l'énergie utilisée de l'énergie c'est de
l'électro lisent ou aujourd'hui celle
contre en gang dans un autre processus
qui s'appelle le stim méthane réforme
inique enfin de le rue mais ça il faut
pas parce que ça c'est le c'est
l'hydrogène gries et mais si vous faites
de l'électrolysé
il faut injecter autant d'électricité
dans le système que ce que l'hydrogène
derrière va vous restituer comme énergie
en brûlant ou en étant utilisé dans une
pile à combustible donc vous vous êtes
comme selon une maxime se lèvent de mon
école ramener au précédent avec quelle
énergie vous faites l'électrolysé de
l'eau avec les centrales nucléaires qui
tourne à vide la nuit a alors
elle tourne pas tant que ça à vis de la
nuit quand même parce que la nuit a pas
de soleil et donc elles vont alimenter
les pays qui ont des panneaux solaires
mais bon mais peu importe
enfin bref l'équation tient par vous
l'émotion ne tient pas pour une autre
raison c'est que quand vous regardez les
en fait tout s'est tu en prennes d'ordre
de grandeur
exactement si demain matin je ne sais
pas combien vous êtes payés ab smart
mais sûrement beaucoup plus qu'un
smicard donc si demain matin on peut
peut je suis président vous savez ah oui
mais aucun je tiens à dire encore une
fois d'ailleurs c'est pour l'emploi qui
me paye vous savez jean marc guay et
créateurs d'entreprise voilà et donc
bravo mais si tu vas à ceux qui ont mis
au point ces d'ici demain matin un
compte tenu des charges que vous avez
contracté dans votre vie d'avant vous
étiez bien payé eux vous dit j'ai pas de
problème je vais me consacrer un autre
métier qui me plaît beaucoup plus sauf
que fera payer 250 euros par mois
quelqu'un peut vous dire vous avez
toujours un salaire mais l'envié aux
grandeurs et c'est l'ordre de grandeur
pour lille alors pour exactement j'ai
publié il ya pas longtemps une petite
tribune dans l'express dans laquelle
j'explique que si par exemple on veut
passer à l'hydrogène tous les le pétrole
des transports en france avec 40
millions de tonnes de pétrole
il faut doubler la production électrique
française alors vous voyez déjà le
pataquès que c'est dans ce pays pour
ajouter un réacteur à vous parler d'eux
sans compter que quand on en a rajouté
un on enferme 2 bravo donc pour doubler
le parc électrique français mais pas
vous amener sur ce terrain là d'ailleurs
à ce que tout le monde vous univers
c'est à dire que le nucléaire ne se
développe bien que dans un cadre
étatique planifié constant et c'est la
raison pour laquelle en ce moment les
deux pays qui sont les grands champions
du nucléaire c'est la chine et la russie
qui ont tous les deux des états forts
déterminer qui savent où ils veulent
aller et qu'ils y vont quand en france
le nucléaire ça fait 20 ans qui sert de
variable d'ajustement pour les accords
électoraux
donc c'est un coup je t'aime un coup je
t'aime pas un coup je te faire marrer
acteurs à coup je te dis quand même
c'est vachement bien ce que vous faites
etc
on ne peut pas faire des choses
sérieuses dans ce genre de contexte donc
temps que des gens pour se faire élire
pensons qu'ils peuvent troquer leur
droit d'aînesse nucléaire contre un plat
de lentilles électorale et on n'ira
jamais nulle part sur ce donc on en fera
un peu de temps en temps pas très bien
et c'est alors c'est un peu en train de
changer
mais le temps que la machine se remette
en marche mais encore pour 5 à 10 ans
parce que c'est des mais vous voyez
c'est ça le hockey hydrogène en ordre de
grandeur mais il faut qu'on aille sur le
alors les entreprises à tout ce qu'on
dit un truc intéressant à faire avec
l'hydrogène
c'est effectivement d'électrolysé de
l'eau avec de l'électricité nucléaire
parce que c'est vous avez un carton
jaune à 80 ou 90% du temps décarbonés et
derrière c'est les applications
industrielles qui sont intéressantes
pour l'hydrogène et des applications
industrielles intéressantes dans un
monde qui se déclare ben y en a deux il
ya la fabrication des engrais parce
qu'on va continuer quand même à utiliser
des engrais azotés un certain temps on
va pas revenir demain matin au fumier de
cheval porte au monde ça il n'y a pas
assez de chevaux et voilà non mais les
ordres de grandeur est là et la deuxième
application industrielle qui pourrait
être très intéressante c'est la
fabrication de l'acier
parce qu'on peut remplacer le charbon
qui s'appelle du coq et noir et non pas
féminin qu'on utilise pour réduire le
minerai de fer donc pour enlever
l'oxygène de l'oxydé de fer
on pourrait remplacer par de l'hydrogène
et à ce moment on peut faire de l'acier
sans co2 enfin avec très peu de co2 on
va dire ça c'est une application
industrielle qui est intéressante
l'acier c'est quand même 4 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde dont 4 % féminin de jean-marc
la flotte mondiale de camions dans les 4
% c'est leur flotte mondiale de camions
très bon chiffre
non mais allons-y sûr parce qu'il faut
qu'on ait il faut qu'on avance quand
même on a beaucoup de temps mais il faut
qu'on avance donc ça ces deux
applications intéressantes en sport vous
oublier mais c'est dans un ancien de
l'hydrogène dans les trois mois là je
prends tout ce que vous venez de me dire
et les ordres de grandeur sont pas là
jean marc je prends tout ce que vous
venez de me dire qui est absolument
passionnant
voilà et je vais j'en sais rien moi
trier mes déchets mais c'est ridicule
en fait alors si c'est absolument
réduction se limite à ça c'est ridicule
en fait la bonne manière de gérer les
déchets c'est d'acheter le moins
possible dans mes qui est l'acte
individuel gens maintenant il a aucun
sens c'est à d'accord sur la il ya un
certain nombre d'actes individuels
en fait tout se répond tiers que vous
pouvez pas dire dans un système là tout
l'effort report repose sur les épaules
du politique des journalistes qui font
mal leur boulot ou d août barsi bassi
parce que c'est des investissements
massifs qui sont nécessaires oui mais
ils sont nécessaires si vous allez
marcher donc en fait à un moment vous
avez 4 ou âge qui doit fonctionner sur
la fac ils doivent tourner dans le même
engrenage
vous avez les consommateurs vous avez
les producteurs vous avez la puissance
publique et vous avez la finance on va
dire voilà et il faut aligner ces quatre
là et chaque mouvement de l'un de ses
quatre ensembles qui permet de faire
progresser le système par effet de
cliquet il est toujours bon à prendre
corps parce qu'il n'ya pas un grand chef
d'orchestre du tout quelque part sur la
planète qui va d'un coup de baguette
magique
exemples tels merlin l'enchanteur tour
exemple rentrons dans le dur et dans le
concret je peux vous donner des chiffres
si vous voulez je veux exemples concrets
article très intéressant que vous avez
relayé du gardien qui m'apprend que le
développement des suv aux états unis
donc c'est les trucs massif 1 c'est pas
les nôtres c'est les américains
ces trois millions et demi de tonnes de
co2 supplémentaires dans l'atmosphère
par an c'est moins que la fermeture de
fessenheim
donc moi je suis industriels de
l'automobile où je suis ouvrier ou
ingénieurs de l'automobile jeudi
on est en train de me flinguer parce que
on va flinguer des suv
ce qui donne de la marge à mon industrie
ce qui permet à mon industrie de vivre
au nom de décision politique et
rationnelle un moment alors ça va plus
marcher
refuser ce sens que vous avez une autre
manière de régler le même problème qui
va pas vous plaire parce que vous êtes
un grand libéral belge fait quand vous
l'abonné
vous faites du protectionnisme
intelligent parce que je pense qu'on ne
règlera pas le problème climatique sans
faire du protectionnisme intelligent et
on n'est pas à armes égales nous les
européens avec les chinois et les états
unis dans cette affaire parce que là on
a affaire à deux pays qui sont uniques
la chine est un seul pays les états unis
si un seul pays dont qui l'on contrôle
aux frontières
donc certes ils sont dans les accords de
libre échange mais en face ils veulent
les adoptés un peu à leur sauce ils ont
qu à se mettre d'accord avec eux mêmes
c'est quand même plus facile de se
mettre d'accord à 27 on est d'accord
vous pouvez très bien réglé le problème
en disant aux constructeurs et j'ai
testé le discours avec alors pas les
dirigeants des constructeurs mais avec
des cadres prix à droite à gauche et
c'est tout ce discours vous leur dites
voilà en france on décide que ont un
plan on convertit les chaînes automobile
à la fabrication de voitures à 2 litres
au cent donc c'est des voitures qui sont
des petites voitures
ça sera pas des suv d'accord derrière je
vous protège contre les importations
donc il ya du protectionnisme et je
force les gens à changer
c'est donc juste à voir mais jean-marc
pas possible bien sûr que si c'est
possible parce que c'est quoi
l'alternative
qu'est ce que c'est que l'alternative
l'alternative rouvrir mais 35 millions
de bagnols 40 millions de tonnes de
pétrole dans ça suffira pas de rouvrir
fessenheim bon donc
je la planification ça nous a quand même
pas si mal réussi 1 dans l'après guerre
ça nous a alors pardon de le dire un mot
ça nous a réussi un moment comme disent
les anglais les vents étaient porteurs
et même les cas y voler vous voyez ce
que je veux dire
john nous à réussir et d'autres vont
signer n'importe quoi ça marchait genou
l'union soviétique de khrouchtchev l
arrivée à planifier l arrivée à waimes
et me laissait penser qu'elle allait y
arriver quand même moins bien que nous
globalement un peu moins bien que devant
ils ont quand même pas bon enfin bref
donc l'or mais je comprends je comprends
ce que c'est ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire à un moment vous
vous dites il faut administrer
l'économie si on veut en sortir il faut
plus l'administré plus la planifier
parce que toutes les choses qui sont du
ressort de la puissance publique et
notamment toutes les infrastructures cdc
saadé pas de temps qu'ils sont très
longs ça dure longtemps
un système de chemin de fer un système
de route un système électrique tout sale
pas de tancer le siècle et vous savez
très bien où est ma convenance nous on
fera ça et on centre on rentrera de se
rendre compte reims les américains ne le
ferons pas une seconde et je m'en fous
quelqu'un parce qu'il ya plein de trucs
qu'on peut faire sans que les américains
s'en donnant à coeur et je vais vous
donner les yeux alors je continue le
comme vous parlez couramment de
jancovici dans le texte vous n'aurez pas
manqué de remarquer que j'ai depuis
maintenant deux ans j'explique partout
que l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
a publié en décembre 2018 un document
que vous connaissez évidemment non non à
les réaliser le world energy outlook qui
dit que le pic de production du pétrole
conventionnel dans le monde est passé en
sans doute annoncer pas sans doute parce
que jancovici dans le texte ou 10 2008
le pic de production du pétrole
conventionnel dormant dépassé en 2008
les machores et de l'union je vous suis
oui alors vous allez voir je veux en
venir derrière 2008 ça vous rappelle
rien alors 74 ça vous rappelle quelque
chose
de quand date le chômage structurel et
l' endettement structurel 74 2008
qu'est ce qui s'est passé accélération
des taux d'endettement de taux d'intérêt
négatifs qui commençaient à arriver
elle est hâtive easing absolument massif
et il fait pas repartir le pib enfin
dans les pays occidentaux
en fait c'est un deuxième choc
énergétique et c'est le début du déclin
du pétrole conventionnel qui en est la
cause
oui d'accord pour le moment on a
compensé le déclin du pétrole
conventionnel avec le schéma est là et
les sables bitumineux
le shell oil est une machine à perdre du
cash c'est à dire que les producteurs de
celle aux etats unis sont à quelques
rôles de schiste les amis shell oil un
pétrole de schiste ils sont ils sont à
cash flow négatif depuis le début de
l'industrie ne regardez pas comme ça
c'est dans les documents qui l'honore
mais si vous le dites mais je crois à
les regarder les sociétés d'intelligence
économique dans ce secteur là il vous le
disent tous ca cash flow négatif
bon donc en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que le quantitative easing à créer
des poches d'investissements absolument
partout une fois que les gens ont leur
pognon il dise en quoi est ce que je
serais d'accord quand quand elle
commence à nous amène vous allez voir
donc le celle là il est un truc qui a
permet de faire de faire croître les
volumes alors que ça gagne jamais
d'argent parce qu'il y avait le
quantitative easing et que par ailleurs
le pétrole est quand même un truc
important pour les états unis mais là le
challenge est à l'arrêt c'est à dire que
les plates formes de forage ont été
divisées par quatre depuis ma chère part
par là bonjour pourquoi mais ça repart
pas et à partir du moment où les chalets
il va s'arrêter de croître simplement
s'arrêter de croître le monde entier
entre en déclin pétrolier structurelles
et c'est pas une année c'est mais aura
beaucoup dans le temps fou non parce que
le pétrole c'est les machines et les
machines c'est le pib donc
à vrai dire on en a besoin de enfin on a
besoin de moins en moins de pétrole
année après année avec les carnicas cité
conseil la virtualisation des n'y a pas
beaucoup ont dénoncé ces voitures dont
on y arrive et là vous voyez j'en sais
rien en fait c'est un combien de consomm
la petite c'est un bon c'est un titre au
100 web bon moi j'ai appris à conduire
dans une 2 chevaux vous savez combien de
consommer cinq ans sauf que l'on me
faisait donc donc en fait on a on a
affecté les gains d'efficacité
énergétique pas du tout à baisser la
consommation des voitures
on a rajouté des airbags des portières
plus épaisses l'autoradio les papilles
dans le cou etc
c'est donc maintenant les bagnoles font
une tonne et demie alors que quand j'ai
appris à conduire elle faisait 500 kg
donc l'efficacité beaucoup moins quand
même juste en passant ça dépend comme de
chevaux à mon avis prenez - le choc
ouais enfin global voiture consomme
beaucoup plus de pétrole donc elles font
faire beaucoup plus de changements
climatiques dont question gens là parce
que quand même moi je voulais vous
ramener sur le sujet des entreprises
votre sujet ouï dire quand on dit tout
ça quand quand on aligne l'ensemble de
dit la même chose aux dirigeants
d'entreprise se croisent à ce moment là
et vous disait pourtant j'ai des clients
et en place - merci jean marc je vais
continuer puis on va attendre me crever
tout en semblant non non carbone 4
faisait 25 personnes il ya trois ou
quatre ans on en fait 75 aujourd'hui non
non donc ça veut dire vous savez c'est
la fameuse parabole du colibri qu'on
voit partout là donc ça veut dire que
chaque entreprise c'est en fait un petit
colibri dans cette histoire qui porte à
chaque porte des gouttes d'eau à celui
d'un bourg ceux qui connaîtraient pas le
colibri qui avec son petit bec pour des
gouttes d'eau pour essayer d'éteindre
les normes fête foraine ils doivent
composer avec plusieurs impératifs les
entreprises ils doivent composer avec le
fait qu'il doit garder des clients mais
ils doivent aussi composer avec le fait
qu'ils doivent garder les employés alors
quand vous êtes dans une entreprise une
certaine taille garder les employés ça
veut dire en recruter tous les ans et en
général dans les entreprises d'une
certaine taille vous avez envie dans le
recrutement annuel d'avoir notamment des
gens dont vous vous dites cela ils sont
plus marquée que la moyenne
c'est eux qui vont me trouver tout un
tas de bonnes idées qui vont faire mon
business futur
il se trouve qu'en ce moment vous avez
de plus en plus de jeunes qui disent
écoutez les vieux ça commence à bien
faire on a l'impression que notre avenir
vous en foutez complètement dont la
figure emblématique de ce mouvement a
great atouts de bergame celui qui est
pour moi une adolescente qui écrit son
angoisse c'est juste c'est tout ça est
juste sahara il faut l'écouter parce
qu'elle ne fait que crier son angoisse
et est donc l'entreprise qui peut
attirer ces gens là doit envoyer des
signes non seulement la tire et qu'elle
s'en prenne aux mille aimé les garder
ouais elle doit envoyer des circassiens
l'occupent on reçoit 100 candidatures
par semaine au caire
et là dedans il ya énormément de gens
qui sont dans des grandes boîtes en
disant je jeu chez moi il se passe rien
j'ai pas envie d'y rester
auquel jean marc et donc et donc vous
donner aux entreprises les moyens de
faire l'affichage qui va bien non mais
ça d'être efficace pour éviter le drame
que vous venez de nous décrire pendant
une dominant parce que je suis le même
dans la sphère privée que devant vous et
donc je tiens le même discours vérité et
on essaye de ne pas travailler avec des
entreprises qui veulent juste faire du
greenwashing celle là non seulement on
veut pas travailler avec mes temps en
temps je ne me prive pas de dire
publiquement que green washing donc non
on essaie donc votre conviction c'est
que tout ce qu'elles peuvent faire l
collectivement va permettre non je suis
limité la casse nous on vient décrivant
mais on a d'alors de limiter ou de
contribuer à limiter parce que personne
ne porte ya pas atlas dans cette
histoire personne ne porte toute la
terre sur ses épaules
par contre il ya des moyens de rentrer
là dedans qui sont des moyens sans
regret alors les moyens sans regret
c'est de se dire par exemple si on doit
avoir des mesures réglementaires qui se
souviennent plus dur sur le co2 et moi
je vous fiche mon billet qu'on va les
avoir
ouais parce qu'un jour on paniquera
devant la forêt de fontainebleau en
flammes et on se dira à ce moment là oh
[ __ ] de rio et crac crac on leur fout
un coup bon donc
le pouvoir politique va procéder par à
coups j'en suis totalement persuadé et
ça sera des à coups réglementaires donc
temps en temps quelques où vous aurez
pas vu venir et par ailleurs le monde va
connaître des catastrophes
le coc vide c'est un avant goût c'est un
apéritif pour d'autres trucs qui vont
arriver plus tard
restons en ouvrons plus de terroir le
nom reste sur 2 restons sur son regret
d'accord on peut agir sans regret
donc on leur dit ben imaginons que le
monde se durcissent là dessus est-ce que
vous avez un plan b de prêt pour ce
genre de sienne de circonstance et bayer
un certain nombre d'entreprises qui me
disent non seulement j'ai pas de plan b
mais ça m'intéresse d'en avoir un donc
on va travailler ensemble à dessus vous
avez des entreprises qui disent nous on
pense qu'on a déjà des offres qui sont
du bon côté de la barrière
alors quand on bosse pour des gens qui
tirent des trains ils vous disent nous
on pense que s'il y avait plus de monde
dans le train et moins de monde en
bagnole ça serait pas plus mal pour le
co2 et quand vous regardez l'équation en
termes d'emploi c'est pas nécessairement
mauvais c'est par exemple au même
endroit globalement c'est pas mauvais
vous allez les gens de la construction
qui en ont mais on est sûr que c'est
mieux d'être dans le train que d'être
dans une voiture qui consomme 2 litres
au cent par exemple si on tout le comme
vous dites oui enfin système contre
système tout comme dit jean marc
jancovici en france oui oui nous prenons
tous une bonne partie du réseau est déjà
construit on fait on fait quand même on
construit quand même pas le réseau tous
les quatre matins m enfin j'ai regardé
le ballast ces nouvelles fort qu'un oui
le bal assurant nouvelles formes et aux
cailloux oui oui mais non mais je fais
mon métier de faire les comptes
c'est même mieux d'être dans un bus que
dans une voiture ah bah oui ça j'ai pas
de doute oui bah ça dépend les bus de la
ratp en milieu de journée qui
fonctionnent au diesel non ils vont
masia l'électricien
on n'est pas 60 toute la journée parce
qu'ils vont regarder mais restons parce
que au bout donc donc donc donc on leur
dit voilà imaginons qu'on a des méthodes
aujourd'hui à carbone 4 pour leur dire
imaginons qu'on soit dans un monde qui
baissent les émissions quelques pour
cent par an est ce que vous voyez où
sont les trucs qui les marchés qui vous
soit interdit les marches et qui vous
qui s'ouvre pour vous et c'est donc on
réfléchit à ce genre de trucs il ya d'un
certain nombre de domaines dans lesquels
les gens sont déjà d'accord pour avancer
parce que il arrive à marier l'économie
et l'écologie
par exemple si vous arrivez à convaincre
les cadres que pour le bien de la
planète il faut diminuer la taille des
voitures de fonction vous avez à la fois
fait un geste pour la planète et fait un
geste pour vos comptes
c'est anecdotique c'est rien c'est un
exemple c'est un exemple mais oui mais
regarde des symboles du truc en
annonçant de parler de ça en fait non ça
dépend des entreprises si vous prenez
une société de services de type banque
ou assurance vous avez deux sujets dans
une entreprise comme ça vous avez ces
placements
c'est le très très gros sujet ouais au
scanner sont poignants voilà et à partir
du moment où on sort ça parce que ça ça
doit devenir un processus instruits dans
le dur etc
pour le reste vous avez trois postes qui
compte son parc informatique ses bureaux
et ses déplacements donc les
déplacements des cadres dans une banque
c'est pas du tout anecdotique c'est les
gros contributeur aux voitures de
fonction et à l'avion donc j'ai pas du
tout est dans la partie fonctionnement
interne c'est pas du tout anecdotique
donc vous avez ces 3 % de 4% des
émissions de greffer chacun chacun à son
échelle après je vous signale qu'avec ce
genre de raisonnement on serait jamais
allé nulle part parce que jamais c'est
le coeur de notre discussion jean-marc
c'est ce pourquoi vous n'avez qu'un seul
pari pascalien qui peut être gagnant
qu'un seul c'est d'essayer
parce que six personnes des seuils vous
êtes sûr que c'est kobe de plus qui
régulera le système parce que le système
sera régulée donc le système sera
régulée par une petite règle de trois
qui s'appelle l'équation de kaya que je
vous invite à regarder que vous avez
déjà lu si vous parlez petite règle de
trois vous dit que tout ce qui ne se
fera pas comme régulation volontaire sur
la sobriété et l'efficacité énergétique
et l'efficacité carbone se fera par
contraction économique et diminution de
la population subit en diminution de la
population subit de truc qui marche bien
c'est la famine et la maladie
même la guerre ça va passer vite mais
par contre ça provoque des famines et
des maladies c'est assez efficace pour
ça donc si on le remarque non restons là
dessus c'est le coeur du truc c'est le
bien du cru je veux bien non mais je
veux bien vous entendre mais je veux à
ce moment là je veux qu'on m'impose ou
plutôt qu'on me préconise des
comportements rationnels
oui en joker à nomexy vous êtes en train
de me dire oui mais c'est aujourd'hui le
gouvernement et par accor dans ce qu'il
décide avec ce que je suis en train de
nous expliquer à la je signe tout de
suite d'où l'attaqué
on est parfaitement d'accord d'accord
d'accord alors je vais vous donner
quelques exemples là dessus on a déjà
engagé en france à fin 2010 820
milliards d'euros
pour développer des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires je dis partout que
c'est une connerie énorme que ça n'a
aucun intérêt sur aucun plan ça ne crée
pas d'emploi parce que ça augmente les
importations donc macroscopiquement ça
en détruit ça ne diminue pas le co2
parce que le solaire fait plus de co2
que le nucléaire mais a oui que le
nucléaire nucléaire l'éolien c'est à peu
près pareil donc ça des carbones pas
l'électricité
ça ne ça n'augmente pas la sûreté
nucléaire parce que contrairement à ce
que tout le monde pense on va garder le
parc nucléaire au backup
c'est exactement ce qu'ont fait les
allemands ils ont gardé le parc existant
en back up
ils ont fermé quelques centrales
nucléaires est ouvert quelques centrales
à gaz mais globalement ils ont la même
puissance installée aujourd'hui un
backup qu'il ya vingt ans by par contre
on va moins s'en servir donc on va
dégrader leur facteur de charge
donc on va dégradé leur rentabilité donc
on va dégrader leur sûreté d'accord donc
c'est un truc de shadocks avec ses
accents milliards d'euros moi je vous
aurais doublé tout km de routes en
france d'une piste cyclable sécurisée
partout en france le même prix est ce
assez efficace dans vos bras
évidemment parce que vous vous en servez
peut-être pas mais moi qui habite en
banlieue parisienne
vous pouvez mieux avec 100 milliards
sont milliards vous pouvez construire
une dizaine de réacteurs nucléaires vont
pas mieux construire une dizaine de
réacteurs nucléaires
en plus je dirais 100 milliards de plus
la cornée de sang mais on était sur 100
milliards qu'on a mis dans les éoliennes
et les panneaux solaires je vous dis moi
je les aurais pas mis là dedans avec 40
milliards vous supprimiez le chauffage
au fuel en france en place et toutes les
chaudières à fuel par des pompes à
chaleur ça c'était très bon pour
supprimer des importations supprimé du
co2 donc augmenter l'emploi juste avec
40,1 après il vous en reste et 80 pour
faire autre chose des piscines non mais
voilà du réacteur 2 enfin c'est fait
série sans doute dix ou douze pas que
mais il faut en faire aussi mais pas que
donc je donc oui je suis je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous aujourd'hui ce
sujet et gérer avec de la lune
amateurisme qui a hier qui est désolant
donc le gouvernement aujourd'hui ne sait
pas faire une règle de trois les
gouvernements et tous les gouvernements
et ses saillies très peur ils sont
encore là et ils ont pas là que d'une
sur une compréhension fine du problème à
traiter
non mais c'est enfin vous avez vous
l'avez dit justement je crois oui c'est
grave mais je crois qu'on fait demander
si vous êtes biologie c'est que vous
savez pas faire la différence entre un
castor est un ver de terre nos jours le
jour ou d opérer un castor c'est quand
même en gardant un bon oui mais vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est
peut-être plus tôt qui y vivent de leur
compréhension pour un plat de lentilles
électorale même pas si seulement si au
moins il était cynique mais c'est même
pas le cas ils sont juste ignorant si au
moins il était cynique ça serait déjà le
début d'une solution ils sont juste
ignorants vous l'avez testé que sur ils
sont juste ignorants bon il va passer
cinq heures à se documenter sérieusement
sur la physique sous jacente du sujet
tant qu'il a reçus de red hat ou de
berck très bien mais il a passé cinq
heures à regarder la physique sous
jacentes bon on est au bout jean marc et
donc comme on a eu une discussion assez
libre je vais dire on n'a pas le cul
sorti des ronces quand même nom mais je
vais revenir au thème de votre chaîne je
pense que c'est une mesure sans regret
pour n'importe quelle entreprise
je vais faire un peu plus tôt programmé
il faut il faut il essayer de mettre
quelques centaines de milliers ou
quelques millions d'euros dans du jus de
cerveau pour comprendre où sont ses
marges de manoeuvre
où sont ces impasses et comment est ce
qu'elle peut naviguer au mieux parce que
ça il s'agit pas de sauver la planète
c'est juste une mesure de sauvegarde
qu'on attend de n'importe quel chef
d'entreprise normalement particulier
vous avez raison et parce que comme vous
l'avez dit de toute façon un moment ça
nous rattrapera et d'autre on est déjà
en train d'être rattrapé partiellement
et plus on attend et plus à faire mal et
les politiques n'auront plus le choix et
la seront bien obligés à un moment quand
même de se documenter comprend we
thought il ya plus d un traçage et à
william une démocratie vous savez la
démocratie n'est pas un système
éternelle il ya nulle part dans les lois
de la physique il est écrit c'est un
système éternelle et l'histoire nous
apprend voilà les amis
il faut quand même se méfier un peu
merci
histoire de se mettre en joie pour le
week-end les amis jean marc jancovici
fils mark
[Musique]